- [Interviewer] Alright, Brett, Brett,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Brett] I was born in Austin, Minnesota.
I got my GED in Albany
County correctional facility.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid.
- Yes, I did.
And then my dad died,
got in the horrible
strike and the mid West.
So that kinda messed us up.
- [Interviewer] The what strike?
- Hormel, the pig plant.
Like she was a stay at home mom.
Right and then all sudden
he ended up doing, you know,
go to school and get reeducated
and all this other stuff.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- I'd describe myself as a loner.
I didn't like going to school.
I didn't really like, we
moved around way too much.
No, I didn't really like fit in anymore.
- [Interviewer] Did you make
friends anywhere you lived?
- Yeah a few friends.
Yeah, but I wasn't like outgoing
or play football or yeah.
Activities with the school
or shit, stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Why was it that
you didn't finish high school?
- I got kicked out of work
program for selling LSD
and then my parents moved
and I tried giving that away
back and I just fell apart.
It actually followed me
there now I think about it.
It followed me there.
- [Interviewer] So you
got involved with drugs
at a very early age?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How did that happen?
- I thought LSD was
the best drug on earth.
It became my life,
14.
- [Interviewer] You
started using LSD at 14?
How often would you use LSD?
- It got to be like
five up every other day.
- [Interviewer] For how long?
- Oh, I'm telling you a long time.
There was ecstasy and
all this other stuff DMT.
- [Interviewer] And what
are you using today?
- Speed,
Methadone,
Xanax.
- [Interviewer] And
you've been living here
in the Tenderloin for how long?
- Since 2000.
- [Interviewer] About 21 years.
Do you have kids of your own?
- I have one son.
I'm an unfit parent by his choice.
- [Interviewer] You were married?
- Nope.
- [Interviewer] Never.
- And not in, check this story out,
I was in jail and I could have got
away with not signing
the birth certificate.
I went ahead and signed it.
My dad said I was the
stupidest man on earth.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever
spent any time with your son?
- No.
When he turned six out here, I called him.
He was like, don't ever call me again.
- [Interviewer] How's that make you feel?
- Very angry
- [Interviewer] Angry at
yourself or angry at him?
- At myself but I'm sad,
and I can't get no drugs out here
for my mental, you know,
deficiency, it's bullshit.
- [Interviewer] What drugs would help you?
- Alprazolam, things like that.
- [Interviewer] What is
your mental deficiency?
- I have a lot of shit.
I have a traumatic brain injury.
I have a crush chip, have a fake hip.
- [Interviewer] What was
the brain injury from?
- From the impact,
the car hitting the tree.
- [Interviewer] How old
were you when that happened?
- Oh, I was 30 something.
- [Interviewer] Were you high or drunk
or anything like that?
- Loaded yeah.
My good buddy checked me in to clearance.
He sued me, sued the grocery store.
He sued everybody.
- [Interviewer] Where
are you living today?
You're in a tent?
- No, I thank the Lord,
I have the Alamo hotel.
- [Interviewer] So you've
got a roof over your head?
Have you been homeless before?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah?
- Fuck yeah, yes sir.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you support yourself now?
- I try to do a little
bit of a shoplifting?
- [Interviewer] And you'll
sell it to a fence and--
- Or I'll try to sell drugs
but people think that I sold drugs.
It's the truth.
One day I couldn't even get
off a bag of speed and they got mad at me.
- [Interviewer] What
emotions do you deal with?
You've been through a lot in your life,
it sounds like.
- Anger, a lot of depression.
Hatred.
- [Interviewer] You feel shame as well?
- Yeah, a little bit.
Listen to this story.
My kid, the grandma,
she had the audacity to say
I wouldn't let you on my property.
And the bitch flies out
here and stays in my room.
- [Interviewer] How
does that make you feel?
- Awful.
And I paid her for rent.
I paid her 250 for rent.
- [Interviewer] Do you believe in karma?
- Yeah I believe in karma,
but I believe in the antichrist.
I believe in karma for sure.
What you do to those will
come back to you, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What events in your life
would affect your karma?
- What affects my karma?
- [Interviewer] What events in your life
would affect your karma?
- Let's see.
I smashed the shit out of my
friend, in that car accident.
I robbed this guy up here
for 300 and some bucks.
That was pretty bad.
What else have I done?
- [Interviewer] Maybe not
being there for your son?
- Yeah but he told me not to be there.
- [Interviewer] Why do you
think that would have been,
was it because you were using drugs?
- I think it, I think
he's grandma coached him.
And then she just said I do the coaching.
- [Interviewer] What's
been the hardest thing
you've had to go through in your life?
- 36 months incarceration.
- [Interviewer] What was that for?
- Just bullshit.
Drinking, drugs, stolen car,
setting up for an eight
ball, which didn't exist.
I found it the next day.
- [Interviewer] Living
the life that you've lived
with a lot of debauchery it sounds like,
What do you think put you on that path?
Do you think your, your
parents, your friends?
- [Brett] Well, I can't
blame nobody, but myself.
I'd like to blame a lot of people.
You know what I mean?
It's just, it's your fault.
- [Interviewer] It's good you
take responsibility for it.
- [Brett] Is it true?
Yeah as long as you beer is
back and oh it's his fault.
- [Interviewer] some people
would say you're a fuck up.
- [Brett] Am I fuck up?
I mean, I work.
I worked as a mason.
- [Interviewer] You've had jobs?
- [Brett] Yeah.
In Connecticut.
Blown-in insulation,
if you're going to do that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's hard.
- [Brett] Man it's good money.
- [Interviewer] So you've had jobs before?
- [Brett] Yeah.
And jobs before, then this car accident,
painted, you name it, washed dishes.
- [Interviewer] So you've tried?
- I've tried.
I have no teeth in my mouth.
- [Interviewer] You've
been in love before?
- Yeah, yup.
Twice.
Really love.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- The best time of my life
was when I was high and
making lots of money.
And it was fun, out here.
- [Interviewer] You think
you'll ever get off the streets
away from drugs?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You do?
How old are you?
- Right now I'm 48.
I mean, I'm thinking
about going to Santa Cruz,
because listen this,
I get these voices,
they're telling me to move.
What do you think about that, sir?
- [Interviewer] Yeah well, I mean,
there's drugs in Santa Cruz too.
There's drugs everywhere.
So sometimes to change your
environment, new friends,
new people around you, can be helpful.
- What about these voices though?
- [Interviewer] Oh the voices?
Well I suspect a lot
of the hallucinogenics
you're playing around with
might be bringing those voices out.
I've never heard voices
- They're vicious.
I wanna cut your dick off.
Be scary.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no,
the things you're playing around with
effect your brain and
maybe you're hearing things
that aren't really happening,
but, but they seem real.
- And scare the shit out of me.
It does.
I mean, I have 10 minutes, it does.
Normal people don't say that, do they?
- [Interviewer] No.
Do you think there's
something about this life
with very little responsibility
that makes it hard to leave?
Hard to change?
- Yeah it was just, you know,
I got sucked back right back here.
I thought it'd be, you know,
cool and things not, you know,
things would be cool, but it hasn't been.
- [Interviewer] It's a rough life.
- I mean, I'm getting my,
I got thrown out in
the middle of the month
and I paid rent by the five oh.
I've gotten a bunch of great stories.
- [Interviewer] What do you worry about?
- What do I worry about?
Being murdered.
A friend of mine said I'm gonna be
gunned down in the streets.
- [Interviewer] Are you religious?
Do you believe in God?
- No maybe I should start believing.
God is going to help you.
- [Interviewer] What's what's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- My whole life or today?
- [Interviewer] In your life.
- Take advantage of a good situation
and don't stop, and
today, be friendly, boom.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- I like it.
- [Interviewer] Well, Brett,
thank you so much for talking with me.
- Well, you're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And good luck with
wherever your life goes from here.
- [Brett] You got it.